bonsoir à toutes et à tous nous sommes
jeudi 17 mars merci de nous retrouver
pour ce nouveau numéro du 7 8 le journal
comme chaque jour nous revenons sur
votre actualité locale entouré de nos
invités également des journalistes de la
rédaction tout de suite on commence avec
les titres de cette édition les
étudiants à nouveau dans la rue après
une première manifestation côté des
salariés le 9 mars dernier ils ont à
nouveau défilé mais cette fois ci à leur
initiative dans les rues aujourd'hui
pour crier leur refus au projet de loi
de travail étudiants et lycéens de saint
quentin en yvelines ont pris pas à la
mobilisation
nous les avons rencontrés avant leur
départ pour la manifestation apparition
le mois de mars est consacré à
l'entrepreneuriat étudiant pour
l'occasion le campus de paris saclay
organise une série de rendez-vous dans
le but de dynamiser la création
d'entreprises sur l'ensemble du
territoire
durant un mois des rencontres
thématiques sont organisées pour nous en
parler ce soir bruno duval président de
financer technologie est partenaire de
l'événement et enfin au programme dans
la chronique sport du jeudi découvrez le
padel un sport très populaire en espagne
mélange de tennis de squash et de pelote
basque et michael almy d'euros est allé
à bois d'arcy un club de paddle vient
juste de s'ouvrir et nous en parlera et
l'actualité de ce jeudi 17 mars et la
jeunesse qui aiment se mobilisent à
nouveau après une première manifestation
aux côtés des salariés
le 9 mars dernier étudiants et lycéens
ont à nouveau défilé aujourd'hui dans
les rues de paris pour crier leur refus
au projet de loi de travail
si le gouvernement se dit désormais
confiant pour le faire passer 22
syndicats étudiants entendent maintenir
la pression jusqu'au retrait total de ce
projet de loi nous avons rencontré les
étudiants et lycéens yvelinois avant
leur départ pour la manifestation à
paris un reportage signé ou des mails
un mouvement qui prend de l'ampleur
c'était 50 à partir de l'ouvèze fut la
semaine dernière pour la manifestation à
paris aujourd'hui ils sont plus de 300
étudiants et lycéens main dans la main
contre le projet de réforme de la loi
travail
il ya tous les ingrédients de jeunesse
politique mais aussi les syndicats
étudiants et lycéens qui sont dans un
collectif unitaire et la jeunesse unie
est capable si elle descend dans la rue
de se faire entendre puisque vacants à
une médiation cent mille personnes à
paris 500000 matin dans toute la france
mercredi dernier on a des premiers
reculs en allah pour la première fois
des variations jeunesse qui sont reçus
par le gouvernement enfin que deux
syndicats étudiants étaient appelés à
manifester aujourd'hui les partis de ces
syndicats de gauche qui manifestent
aujourd'hui contre le projet du
gouvernement socialiste
justement là c'est la gauche qui ne
renie pas ses valeurs qui justement
manifeste pour sauver ses valeurs on est
contre la précarité c'est pas un
gouvernement de gauche que vous qu'on a
en ce moment quoi on a jusqu'au 30 mars
pour monter en pression parce que le 31
mars c'est la grosse date de
manifestation intersyndicale
mais si l'âge si jamais le breton ne
pipa on va pas s'arrêter un peu le 31
mars sera pas la dernière date
l'objectif pas de négociations mais un
retrait pur et simple du projet de loi
des jeunes qui veulent se faire entendre
comme la nouvelle génération cpe
besson tu puisses de cet avis nous avons
posé la question à ceux qui ne sont pas
allés à la manifestation
je suis pour ma part ce qu'on est un peu
les citoyens de plus tard demain elles
sont d'être légitime mais je pense
qu'elles seront pas acceptés c'est un
peu trop gros je trouve qu'ils demandent
je pense que c'est bien parce que c'est
notre futur je trouve que c'est plutôt
une bonne chose
après est ce que ça va faire changer ça
c'est une autre histoire encore
étudiants et lycéens a pris une
assemblée générale à lui vs plus ont
ensuite manifesté dans les rues de saint
quentin avant de rejoindre la
manifestation votre avis
bien sûr et plusieurs milliers
d'étudiants étaient réunis à la place de
la bastille à 14 heures à paris des
heurts ont éclaté pendant la
manifestation où des casseurs se
seraient mêlés au cortège
dans la matinée son soutien aux
établissements scolaires étaient bloqués
selon le ministère de l'éducation
nationale sur les 2500 blessés public de
france à savoir qu'une nouvelle journée
d'action contre le texte porté par la
ministre ou myriam el khomri est prévue
le 31 mars prochain
et passons maintenant à notre entretien
du jour le mois de mars et le mois de
l'entrepreneuriat étudiant dans ce cadre
une série de rendez-vous s'appuyant sur
l'entrepreneuriat étudiant est organisée
et cela dans le but de dynamiser la
création d'entreprises sur l'ensemble du
territoire du campus de paris-saclay
durant un mois des rencontres
thématiques sont organisées par
l'ensemble des acteurs du campus afin
d'encourager l'entrepreneuriat et de
valoriser également le territoire pour
nous en parler ce soir bruno duval
bonsoir merci d'être venus merci la
venue sur notre plateau vous êtes le
président de financer technologies vous
est également partenaire de l'opération
alors cette opération est une grande
première pourquoi avoir lancé cette
initiative
alors il s'agit effectivement initiative
qui répond à une tendance de fond qui
est l'entrepreneur étudiants qui qui
vraiment c'est a démarré il ya deux
tours de 2008 après la crise de 2008 on
a vraiment vu comment c'est le poindre
une vague d'entrepreneurs ya dans les
écoles
donc des entreprises créées par des
jeunes en fin d'études les écoles ont
pris le relais toutes les grandes écoles
du plateau de saclay ont vraiment comme
supoptique et d'autres sont vraiment
pris le relais pour décupler cet effort
l'année dernière il ya eu il en tient
une journée qui s'appelle peps qui est
le l'entrepreneur étudiants du plateau
de saclay c'est une amie qui a été créée
il ya 5 6 ans déjà et puis qui prend de
l'ampleur donc il ya une journée qui
s'est passé le 10 mars dernier 73
projets ont émergé de cette journée ceux
de ce jeudi 10 mars et donc à comparer à
1 183 projets à comparer à 70 projets
nés dernière donc une croissance déjà de
nombreux projets qui ce qui se construit
ce conte qui se comptent s'observe
depuis déjà plusieurs années
donc c'est par respect nouveau et donc
il ya notre objectif il a été
d'accompagner cette création c'est
dynamique de création qui me paraît très
très souhaitable pour le pour le
territoire et pour le pays et donc de
pouvoir l'accompagner sur différentes
étapes de la création donc on a créé des
après midi dès jeudi après midi donc le
17 le 24 et le 31
avec des étapes complémentaires celle
d'aujourd'hui le 17 c'est fine mass
start up c'est à dire nous y reviendrons
dans quelques instants
vous n'êtes pas et sort pas le seul
partenaire il ya beaucoup d'acteurs du
mot entreprises qui sont là pour
accompagner les étudiants comment ils se
sont mobilisés justement pour voiler les
aider et gray les accompagner d'accord
alors nous nous sommes effectivement
statines saclay une somme deux
partenaires organisateurs de ces
journées avec pète ce don qui est qui et
le structurent dynamiser effectivement
sur plateau de saclay et sur la
diversité d'orsay qui est active
là-dessus le don comprend la relève de
ça il ya beaucoup de partenaires
impliqués donc il ya toutes les
plateformes enfin des plateforme de
crowdfunding qui viennent participer
il y a des incubateurs là par exemple
aujourd'hui ça se passe les ouailles qui
est l'accélérateur de la bnp qui est
basée à massy
donc l'idée a été vraiment sur
l'ensemble du territoire que ce soit sur
massy que ce soit sur orsay où que ce
soit sur saint quentin en yvelines
d'avoir véritablement un mois entier
dynamisant l'entrepreneur étudiants
alors justement à tout le long du mois
de mars il a donc différents événements
thématiques sont organisées
aujourd'hui c'était fine maille start up
vous pouvez nous en dire un peu plus ce
qu'est ce que c'est voilà alors donc
l'idée c'est on part d'une date qui est
la création d'entreprise les gens ont le
projet le projet crée parfois c'est
créer parfois c'est avant la création
donc l'idée c'est d'aider ces projets
qui se lancent à trouver des ressources
stagiaires ou contractuels des emplois
pour pouvoir lancer leur activité
le problématique des start-ups et
qu'elles n'ont pas de visibilité
vis-à-vis des jeunes diplômés et non pas
une partie par des salons il n'y a pas
de chasseurs de têtes pour les recruter
ou des drh pour les recruter dans les
écoles ou ailleurs et donc l'idée ça a
été véritablement de fournir un lieu de
un lieu de rendez vous qui va permettre
à des à des start-up de se présenter à
un public de jeunes soit stage et en fin
d'études soit de jeunes en recherche
d'emploi pour pouvoir trouver un emploi
dans une start up et participé à la
création de dès le début la housse et
foisonnant là où c'est passionnant de
participer ce toujours passionnant enfin
c'est très passionnant début et donc de
quoi participer à cette dynamique de
création de valeur alors il ya deux
autres étapes donc le 24 mars eyjafoll
start up et le 31 mars foster my start
up
voilà c'est la suite logique les autres
aux étapes voilà exactement donc après
avoir trouvé l'équipe pour pour
travailler compléter l'équipe si
nécessaire eh bien il faut aussi du
financement
donc c'est le financement c'est fun my
start up
donc ça c'est jeudi 24 ça se passe à
saint quentin juste à côté d'ici donc là
il y aura une vingtaine trentaine de
projets qui vont rencontrer des
individuellement des financeurs alors ça
se passe en deux étapes pour faire la
première étape ce sont des financières
qui ne se présentait donc toute la
chaîne de financement le but c'est de
remettre de l'ordre dans la tête des
créateurs qui sont très amicale
financement ça un peu un problème quand
on veut créé sa start up qu'on est
jeunes on sait pas trop verte histoire
oui c'est un peu ça et il ya beaucoup de
choses qui existent on a du mal à mettre
la charrue avant les boeufs afin de
mettre les choses dans l'ordre
donc par exemple il ya des financements
qui sont plutôt adapté avant la création
comme les prêts d'honneur par exemple
alors qu'ils peuvent marcher après mais
qui sont surtout adapté avant la
création et puis à des financements qui
sont plutôt adapté après la création que
les business angels qui seront présents
les réseaux bien sans gel des yvelines
sont présents les réseaux de business
angels que je représente d'ailleurs du
plateau de saclay sont présents
également
donc tous les partenaires du financement
sont présents et ils viendront
s'expliquer comment fonctionne le
financement en fonction du moment où
mais dans sa phase de développement de
l'entreprise et il ya des rendez vous
individuels qui sont organisées ensuite
avec les projets qui seront présents
entre il ya même la bpi qui vient donc
tous les acteurs vraiment du financement
de la chaîne on à mort en démarrage
selon présent et le 31 mars donc foster
maïs start up c'est à orsay c'est ça
voilà c'est au proto 204 un lieu
mythique alors c'est qui il a donc c'est
toute la chaîne d'accompagnement donc
une fois qu'on a trouvé l'équipe
enfin qu'on ait eu l'idée travailler ou
l'équipement trouver des financements
maintenant faut l'accompagnement donc ça
va des incubateurs des pépinières et des
accélérateurs donc tous les acteurs sont
là pour mon expliquer justement start up
qui sont les structures localement 1 sur
plateau de saclay qui vont pouvoir les
aider et les accompagner dans leur phase
de création de l'idf a toujours pareil
dans fonction du stade où ils sont qui
seront les mieux adaptés aux solutions
pour les a compris qu est ce pas trop
difficile quand on est étudiant de
conseiller à les études et projets
d'entreprises tant qu'on n'a pas
spécialement de visibilité sur le monde
du travail
alors oui tout à fait c'est une bonne
façon quand même d'y rentrer un faut
savoir qu'il est gros projets qui
marchent sont des projets qui sont alors
on dit toujours les créateurs souffre
une dizaine d'années d'expérience pour
créer il faut aussi les gros projets qui
marchent qui sont les licornes
d'aujourd'hui en france sont souvent des
projets qui ont été montés par des
jeunes ou des gens en face à ces jeunes
un donc
donc il faut une certaine inconscience
quelque part un pur donc le il faut du
temps devant soi aussi
donc c'est je pense que c'est un bon
moment pour créer un oui effectivement
il ya un manque d'information donc on
est là pour fournir cette information au
maximum mais je pense que c'est aussi un
bon moment et c'est une bonne étape dans
la vie d'un jeune de se lancer dans la
création plus tôt possible et donc d'en
bénéficier
dans sa carrière pour le pour le futur
c'est vraiment un espace idéal que ce
soit sur un échec ou une réussite de
toute façon il va en bénéficier
aujourd'hui à ce que la france le
gouvernement français l'économie aussi
plus globaux globalement compte sur les
jeunes pour voilà relancer les économies
et pondre un concurrent au niveau des
start up par rapport aux états unis où
on peut être en allemagne le monde et
sert thomas france supporte pas mal
c'est assez intéressant alors j'ai pu
les chiffres en tête et exaltant mais il
ya en europe
en tout cas la dynamique est bonne la
france reste une faille avoir d'autres
soucis des soucis notamment de
financement sur les tours assez
important mais par exemple sur les
phases d'amorçage aujourd'hui on peut
trouver des financements que ce soit par
des business angels que ce soit par des
plateforme de crowdfunding il ya même
des projets plus avancés du crâne
lanigan il ya toute une dynamique qui
s'est mis en place
donc on peut trouver des financements
qui permet de démarrer presse et sur les
tours un peu plus évolué ou là
effectivement c'est plutôt des fonds
étrangers qui vont intervenir c'est un
petit peu dommage on manque de fonds de
pension en france c'est un autre
problème j'en parlerai pas mais le
le il existe aujourd'hui une vraie
dynamique pour aider en france pour
aider la création de start-up il ya une
vraie appétence des étudiants une vraie
appétence des collectivités et ont peu
de tout on peut ne se sont félicités
également sur plateau de saclay alors
une dernière question avant de finir cet
entretien par rapport à il travaille
donc de myriam elle que maurice faut
penser voilà il ya des jeunes qui se
mobilisent parce qu'il ya d'autres
jeunes qui trouvent que c'est une bonne
idée pour se lancer dans
l'entrepreneuriat selon vous alors je
parle pas trop de la loi parce qu'elle
ne sait pas trop où elle en est mais
mais je crois que oui effectivement il
ya il y a il y a une grosse dynamique
aujourd'hui donc effectivement on peut
dire qu'il ya deux des jeunes qui
manifestaient aujourd'hui je pense que
là on est à l'opposé on est plutôt sur
des jeunes qui vont plutôt prendre leur
destin en main et vouloir se lancer dans
la création d'entreprise
je pense qu'encore une fois c'est c'est
une grande chance pour le territoire et
les papilles merci beaucoup
bruno duval d'être venus sont apatrides
avoir répondu à notre question alors je
le rappelle encore deux rendez-vous fond
de maïs start-up le 24 mars et foster
marie start-up le 31 mars si vous voulez
retrouver toutes ces informations
concernant donc le mois de
l'entrepreneuriat étudiant à paris
saclay toutes les informations à
retrouver sur les stades qui s'affiche
en bas de votre écran et la sixième
semaine de l'industrie c'est en ce
moment et jusqu'au 20 mars la chambre de
commerce et de l'industrie de versailles
continue ses actions pour cet événement
ce rendez vous permet au grand public en
particulier aux jeunes de découvrir à
l'industrie et ses métiers en
rencontrant ses acteurs pour mieux
appréhender les enjeux de la filière
mardi 15 mars
elle proposait à une vingtaine
d'entrepreneurs et d'entreprises du
réseau coaction yvon de rencontrer une
centaine de lucien élèves en bts du
lycée villa roi chaque représentant
d'entreprises échangé avec six élèves
pendant près de 20 minutes
andrea doria animatrice du réseau qu'aux
actions pour la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie de versailles been nous en
part à l'écouté là du côté des
entreprises il
il aime beaucoup échangé avec les gens
leur faire comprendre la réalité du
monde de l'entreprise du monde du
travail les savoir-être travail le
savoir être en entreprise
leur apprendre voilà qui a un parcours
mais pas écrit et que ça s'écrit petit à
petit du côté des
et des jeunes ben il j'aime beaucoup le
porte unités de rencontrer des chefs
d'entreprise des différentes entreprises
des différentes activités qui peuvent
leur apporter une idée différente à
celle qui aimerait soit en cours ça nous
permet de découvrir des entrepreneurs
qu'on veut se faire leur vie enfin coup
commencé comme nous ils tenaient le
précité entre comme dans leur propre
entreprise
évoluer dans l'entreprise d'accueil ont
commenté les technologies à présent à
l'occasion de son deuxième anniversaire
l'institut vd comme inauguré aujourd'hui
jeudi 17 mars
le premier atelier de prototypage de son
futur centre d'électrification
cet atelier va permettre à bd comme
d'optimiser ses recherches pour réduire
la consommation d'énergie et les
émissions des véhicules actuels le
développement de l'électrification
favorise la rupture technologique qui
permet à terme à l'industrie française
automobile de mettre sur le marché des
véhicules électriques accessibles au
plus grand nombre les explications
techniques avec dominique l'hôtelier
responsable du secteur électrification
de l'institut bd comme à l'ensemble des
machines que vous avez dans cet atelier
va nous permettre de travailler en
boucle courte ce qu'on appelle en boucle
courte c'est à dire que sans un atelier
de deux de ce type
habituellement il faut six à neuf mois
pour réaliser une machine prototype
alors qu'ici on va pouvoir diviser ce
temps là par dix et donc accélérer la
sortie des innovations que nous allons
travailler dans l'institution et nous
continuons à part les transports mais
cette fois-ci allons voir du côté des
trains il est un maillon essentiel de la
chaîne de l'information voyageur le
poste de coordination de l'information
est un lieu stratégique situé près de la
gare de l'est à paris une petite cellule
chargée de transmettre en temps réel les
informations sur la circulation de vos
trains sur le réseau transilien retard
accident de voyageur ou fermetures de
ligne les agents sont suivre ces
informations sur les applications
mobiles sites internet mais aussi sur le
fil twitter
regardez ce reportage signé william l
ici nous avons les lignes n et u
constatons que les trains qui sont au
vert sont à l'heure ici nous avons deux
trains qui sont légèrement en retard ce
sont des trains vides qui s'achemine
tranquillement vers leurs vers leurs
dépôts c'est ici derrière tous ces
écrans que l'information prend forme et
transit
sco voyageurs nous sommes au poste de
coordination de l'information du réseau
transilien chargé de transmettre les
messages aux voyageurs sur les
différentes plateformes numériques nous
l'information elle vient du cot le code
c'est le centre opérationnel transilien
en fonction de la gravité de l'incident
et en fonction des prescriptions qui
nous sont données on va diffuser ou non
l'information sur sur les médias distant
application transilien site internet ou
transilien moby les médias les voilà
retard accident suppressions de trains
seront envoyées sur ces réseaux
permettant la notification de
l'information ou clients l'impact du de
l'incident doit être suffisamment
significatif pour que le client
change sa stratégie de déplacement pour
ça que quand on diffuse une information
il faut que l'allongement de temps de
parcours subie par le client soit
supérieure à 10 minutes en dessous de 10
minutes
l'information est relayée en gare via
les écrans info gare et via les annonces
sonores
les notifications sont aussi relayés sur
le fil twitter du réseau qui compte
soixante mille abonnés ici quatre
personnes travaillent en tant que
permanent pour le relais d'environ 300
incidents par mois en février seulement
12 incidente été relevés sur la ligne
rennes et deux sur la ligne e
des chiffres très faible comparé à
l'ensemble du réseau
le pc info s'inscrit dans le cadre d'un
travail contractuel avec le stif avec
pour objectif de produire une meilleure
information dans le cadre d'un trafic
perturbé et risque ferroviaire
comportement citoyen à bord des trains
ou encore l'importance d'acheter et de
composter son billet ce sont
quelques-uns des thèmes développés ce
matin au lycée henri matisse attrape les
élèves de la troisième classe prépa pro
ont rencontré un agent d'intervention en
milieu scolaire de la sncf
chaque année 30 agents conducteurs de
trains agents de terrain ou agents
commerciaux échange avec 25000 jeunes
franciliens
les précisions au micro de mélanie poté
pour la sncf c'est ce qu'on appelle les
coûts évités
lorsqu'on rencontre des jeunes demain on
sait que c'est je la vends en prêter nos
lignes et donc ils vont être au fait du
danger quand il va emprunter en ligne
demain aujourd'hui même les gens que
j'ai rencontrés de suite la lgv a pu
tirer le signal d'alarmé
eelv a pu bloquer les portes parce qu'il
sait que ces peuples à bloquer s'arrêta
demi-train je crois que ça fait partie
aussi de
l'éducation à la citoyenneté que quand
même notre ministre nous demande
grandement de mettre en place dans les
établissements scolaires le vivre
ensemble la laïcité et nous refermons
cette page transport et prenons à
présent la direction de plaisir c'est
une nouvelle étape dans la création
future des fresques du vally bout après
une réunion de présentation et de
lancement en février dernier la société
en charge des fresques va maintenant à
la rencontre des 4000 habitants du
quartier la première rencontre a eu lieu
hier
retour sur cette rencontre consacrée aux
plus jeunes un reportage signé mélanie
poquet et camille lambert
quelle est l'histoire du val ibuki vie
c'est grâce aux réponses des habitants
du quartier que les fresques vont voir
le jour tout ça va nous permettre à nous
designer artiste peinte de citer
création de pouvoir penser les fresques
monumentales qu'on va écrire qu'on va
dessiner sur sur leur mur c'est à dire
leur peau et faire que justement ils
soient fiers de ce qui va être réalisée
aujourd'hui la page est blanche pour
nous donc c'est à travers ces
témoignages qu'on sera en mesure de de
pouvoir créer tout simplement la page
blanche ce sont les façades des
immeubles du vally bout les 4000
habitants du quartier sont mis à
contribution et les idées fourmillent
déjà on voudrait que ça retrace vingt de
l'histoire va des habitants leurs
souvenirs à savoir bandes et les moments
va dire de joyeux puisque moi
n'a pas que des moments joyeux dans la
vie hein malheureusement comme ça on va
dire à travers des promenades juste en
regardant les murs des bâtiments
voilà vous nous donner le sourire avec
dame des fleurs avec pecqueur avec plein
de choses
paysages et fleurs l'herbe les arbres
des bâtiments str j'aimerais bien qu'il
ya des couleurs vives des fleurs des
dessins des des arbitres de today
autre hic dans un mois les designers
reviendront avec des propositions de
concepts les habitants donneront à
nouveau leur avis et les maquettes
définitifs seront présentés début juin
lors du festival escales d'ailleurs et
nous recevons à présent à sur ce plateau
notre journaliste sportif à michael et
demi d'euros pour sa chronique sport
bonsoir michael vous allez bien ce que
vous êtes bien reposé après votre petite
semaine de vacances au stif va merci de
me prendre de mes nouvelles en tout cas
et je suis en pleine forme pour cette
chronique du jour j'espère qu'elle va
elle vient pour votre grand retour
quel est justement le thème de notre
chronique aujourd'hui est ce que vous
connaissez le padel ce sport ne vous dit
peut-être rien floral mais il est ultra
populaire en espagne la fédération
espagnole compte plus de 40 me licencier
3 millions de pratiquants pratiquants
section loisirs dans la péninsule
ibérique
en argentine on trouve également plus de
deux millions d'adeptes et ce sport
commence à se développer dans les pays
asiatiques en milieur milieu urbain en
france le pad elle est affiliée depuis
2014 à la fédération française de tennis
un club vient tout juste d'ouvrir à bois
d'arcy rue abel gance et compte déjà
plus de 50 voire le responsable médical
b ration nous présente les règles de ce
sport c'est un sport de raquette qui se
joue sur un terrain de 20 mètres de long
10 mètres de large avec un fil au milieu
et on joue exclusivement de compte de
ces la surface un gazon synthétique
recouvert de sable et on renvoie la
balle dans le camp adverse on a la
possibilité d'aller se rebondir contre
la paroi de fonds et des côtés avant de
la renvoyer dans le camp d'en face pour
lancer la balle dans le camp d'en face
si on a besoin d'une d'une raquette
d'une raquette je vois que vous ciblez
florane et on regarde justement mellick
nous présente justement les spécificités
de cette raquette
si nous rackettent qui fait 38 cm de
long pour 4 cm d'épaisseur
à l'intérieur c'est que de la mousse qui
a recouvert de carbone on retrouve le
grip en fait le même que l'on au tennis
légèrement plus petit est très variable
ferme après 35 ans de gramat et très
maniable et on la contrôle bien ce qui
fait qu'on renvoie vite la balle très
facilement en france on est très loin
d'avoir les trois millions de
pratiquants espagnol mais nous avons
tout de même 3000 joueurs de padel dans
l'hexagone des français en tout en même
remporté les championnats d'europe en
décembre dernier aux pays-bas
les filles sont également
vice-championne d'europe ce qui prouve
que ce sport se développe plus
plus dans notre pays c'est un sport
extrêmement convivial très ludique très
simple les règles s'apprennent très
rapidement c'est comme au tennis à
différence c'est qu'on a des vitres en
doit jouer avec les litres c'est un
sport qui est donc très ludique très
simple à mettre en place sur avec eux
avec des jeunes avec des joueurs avec
toutes catégories d'âge
tout le monde peut le faire moi je suis
pas issu du tennis jamais fait de tennis
non plus rapidement rapidement ouais
c'est très plaisant quoi tu étais était
dedans tout de suite le padel c'est
aussi très bon pour le cardio la balle
ne sort presque jamais du terrain et les
temps morts sont rares les parties sont
donc plus rythmé côté nice nous avons
interrogé des joueurs à la sortie de
l'entraînement je sors d'un entraînement
donc j'ai les jambes qui sont déjà bien
lors d'un déjà c'est très physique très
technique aussi parce que du coup ce
très très passionnant moi j'ai découvert
ça y est un an et c'est vrai que voilà
c'est très sympa de pouvoir galoper à
gauche à droite
en tout cas si vous voulez vous mettre
remettre en forme avant l'été floral
il ne faut pas hésiter à pratiquer le
padel c'est convivial facile d'accès
même si vous n'avez jamais pratiqué à le
tennis et c'est bon pour la forme
vous avez essayé le fait penser à un
sport très ludique très sympa et je vous
recommande en tout cas à tout le monde
j'espère que voilà je vous ai convaincus
avec cette chronique et j'espère qu'on
va essayer samson et bah oui si on fait
un double michaël je suis partante on
termine à votre chronique par rendez
vous sportif sera monté ce week-end
un rendez-vous à ne pas manquer pour les
aficionados du handball le tournoi
international junior féminin
qualificatif pour les championnats du
monde 2007 en russie est organisée de ce
vendredi 18 à ce dimanche 20 mars au
palais des sports pierre de coubertin
plaisir la france liseret la macédoine
et la slovénie s'affronteront dans ce
mini tournoi pour gagner leur billet
pour la compétition
seule la première est qualificative les
rencontres sont ouvertes au public
donc c'est une grosse rencontre merci à
michael on vous retrouve dans quelques
instants pour votre talk sport quel sera
le programme cette émission a été moins
l'eau à la bouche
alors avec la bande nous allons parler
de la compétition d'aviron les régates
de versailles nous allons également
parlé de gymnastique avec le club j'aime
d'elancourt maurepas et de toute
l'actualité sportive du département
flore
si beaucoup michael on ne va pas rater
ça on se retrouve la semaine prochaine
pour une nouvelle chronique
c'est à présent la fin de cette édition
merci de nous avoir suivis à suivre vous
venez de l'entendre on retrouvera
michaël elle me d'euros pour son talk
sport si on parlait sport sur
l'actualité sportive yvelinoise demain
vous retrouver ou le fruit des riches y
pour l'essentiel de l'actu et mélanie
poké vous donnera des idées de sorties
dans le 7-8 week-end quant à moi je vous
retrouve lundi pour une nouvelle édition
du journal je vous souhaite donc une
très bonne soirée et un excellent week
end